Vous parlez à beaucoup de
psychologues sont débordés,
comment qualifier cette vague
d'anxiété, de troubles qui
déferlent actuellement, sur une
échelle de un à 10 on est rendu
à combien?
travail on est rendu à une
intolérance assez élevée.
Probablement, 17. 58. Vous savez
l'anxiété à monter depuis le
début de la pandémie et les
demeurer. Je pense qu'on peut
qualifier la dernière vague
comme étant un peu la vague de
trop. La vague de la fatigue
. Il y a quelqu'un dans
le reportage qui parlait des
réserves qui étaient limitées.
On avait tous des réserves mais
s des limites à nos
capacités adaptatives. Quand le
cerveau est fatigué, il perd un
erspective. Il a
l'impression que les choses sont
peut-être plus sombres qu'elles
ne le sont réellement. On ne
voit pas la lumière tunnel.
Parfois on est pas capable. Pour
la franche la plus sensible, en
tout cas qui est le plus de
problèmes, cet homme dans le
reportage d'une phrase trèsimpos
moyens, et j'ai pu aller
chercher de l'aide. Je ne peux
pas imaginer si je n'avais pas
été vu par un professionnel. Les
gens qui n'ont pas les moyens,
comment font-ils pour avoir de
l'aide actuellement.
- C'est ça qui est dramatique,
les gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens ou les ressources, parce
que ça prenne connaissance du
système, des ressources
psychologiques même pour aller
chercher de la neige. De l'aide.
Les populations qui sont plus
vulnérables qui ont moins de
moyens, je pense qu'il faut
s'occuper de ces gens-là, il va
falloir un moment donné, et
assez rapidement faire de la
santé mentale un enjeu de santé
publique. Mettre la même
énergie, la même vitesse de
traitement pour donner accès aux
gens comme on l'a fait pour
essayer d'enrayer la contagion.
- Mais quand Monsieur karma
annonce aujourd'hui, un. 1
milliard sur cinq ans, et 375
millions de plus, est-ce que ça
ça vous rassure,?
- Ça c'est la partie qui
m'inquiète il y a des points
forts de ce plan d'action là,
c'est un plan d'ac
veut faire la promotion et la
sensibilisation de la santé
mentale. Donc il y ait grand
montant qu'on le fasse. On veut
cibler les jeunes
faire le partenariat avec le
communautaire. La partie sur le
traitement, sur l'accès aux
services psychologiques, sur
l'accès à la thérapie je ne la
vois pas, comme je ne vois pas
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour
garder -
psychologues dans le réseau
public. ent une péent une péent.
On va avoir besoin d'eux pour
traiter la population ce qui
m'inquiète, c'est qu'on a un âge
d'accès à ce service-là pour la
populatia un agita un agita un t
d'accès, on va diminuer la
qualité des soins.
- Pourquoi un finisseur, un
doctorat qui entre os public n'y
reste pas?
- Les conditions de pratique, le
docteur a étudié beaucoup
versité, en
moyenne huit ans et les
conditions dans lesquelles on
les met actuellement sont des
irritants. Comme le manque de
reconnaissance, le manque
d'accès à de la formationsée, oe
de possibilités. Je comprends ce
que peuvent psychologues faits.
Moi comme présidente, je ne
négocie pas les conditionses mat
inquiétant parce que ça cause un
enjeu d'accès. À ce service à la
population. Je pense qu'on vaav.
De façon très concrète,
quelqu'un qui appelle au CLSCKin
psychologue, dans ce qui a été
annoncé ce matin par le minus,
est-ce que le temps d'attenteri?
vous ne voyez pas beaucoup dedi.
- Si vous adressez demain à
CLSC, pour avoir une
psychothérapie il y a bien des
CLSC où ça n'existe pas. Avant
même de celle des s'adressés au
temps d'attente, il faudrait se
reconnaît les effectifs. Les
patients, ce qu'il demande
souvent ses on veut avoir des
gens pour nous écouter. Et non
pas uniquement une médication
par exemple. Ils ont besoin d'un
lien et d'un facteur humain. Je
pense qu'il faut se pencher, et
loin de moi l'idée de penser
qu'il n'y a que les services
psychologiques sont nécessaires,
ça prend un ensemble de serv
et ça fait parti du plan
d'action. Je ne vois pas la
portion où on veut rehausser et
même ramener à ce que si
t-elle une dizaine d'années au
regard des effecti
- Combien il manque de
psychologues au Québec,
indépendamment des publics ou
privés?
- C'est difficile de dire qu'il
en manque, on a 9000
psychologues. Dans le réseau
public on n'en a perdu test
presque 450. Ce qui est
problématique actuellement,
c'est qu'il y a que 25 % des
doctoran
emploi dans le réseau public, et
de ses 25 % là, il y en a 40 %
qui vont quitter dans les années
qui suivent leur embauche.
- Pour le privé, vous dîtes
qu'il y en a assez. Nos listes
d'attente ont trop de monde.
- C'est tout à fait juste, on
est dans une situation sans
précédent. Moi je n'ai jamais vu
ça. Avant on disait au moins
quand les gens ont de l'argent,
ce qui n'était pas une somme
se
faire soigner. Alors même si le
cas maintenant, c'est trèsr acct
parce que justement la santé
mentale de la population a été
mise à mal. On a travaillé sur l
faut chercher de toutes les
façons possibles. Dans le plan
d'action il y a plusieurs
éléments qui permettent un
accès, il ne faut pas oublier
une portion de service qui faite
national depuis longtemps.
- Dr Carmant nous parlait du vos
vous, ils doivent en principe
vous aiguiller vers quelque
chose de concret.très bien, dana
mesure où quand on appelle à
huit heures, on parle à
quelqu'un qui est en mesurer de.
Souvent ça va comme un
dépistage. Mais pour orienter
quelqu'un, déjà il faut avoir
évalué en partie le problème
dans la personne besoin. Il faut
est capable d'offrir les
services dont la personne abesoe
disponible. Ça fait parti du
plan d'action mais ça fait
longtemps qu'on entend ça. Onve.
- Kristina Groves, j'espère
qu'on va espérer que ça bougepÇa
débouche aussi parfois sur des
hospitalisations.
- Tout ce qui ne se traite pas
risque de s'aggraver et de se
complexifier. C'est prévenir de
traiter au bon moment et
rapidement quelqu'un qui a d